today the families of American detained
in Iran will testify before Congress
Iran is accused of using for prisoner to
extract political and financial
concessions from Washington Margaret
Brennan is at the White House where
President Trump is taking a hard line
against the Iranian regime she spoke to
one of those families yesterday Margaret
good morning good morning well president
Trump issued a sharp warning of serious
consequences if Iran doesn't release all
imprisoned Americans and stop using
hostage taking as a tool of state policy
everything I hear terrifies me and it
terrifies me more and more everyday
every day Babak namazi is pleading for
the release of his brother 45 year old
ceramic namazi an 80 year old father
Bakr imprisoned in Iran for nearly two
years all I asked for obviously is for
the safe return and for their immediate
return before it's too late before it's
too late
what do you mean by that well what I
mean is the conditions of both my father
and cmx
are horrible my father is not doing well
White House officials told CBS News they
were increasingly concerned about
Barker's deteriorating health and say
Siana
seen here in this propaganda video has
been mistreated due in part to his US
citizenship Bakr and sciama car being
held inside Iran's notorious Evin prison
something Iranian Foreign Minister Javad
Zarif denies but Karin namazi an
American citizen he's in his 80s he's in
failing health why not release him as a
voluntary ingestion he's not behind bars
but he is not free to leave the country
and as I said the is he under house
arrest the executive and this is what
I'm told the White House called Zarif's
claimed false I was shocked and
astonished when I heard that in fact
today my father and brother had both
visits active in prison so I have no no
idea why
foreign ministers I would make these
claims these are very very painful words
to hear whatever they're not true in
2016 Iran did release Americans
following the international agreement to
freeze its nuclear program and
only in exchange for seven Iranian
prisoners namazi attorney Jared Ganser
do you think Iran's looking for another
prisoner swap we would strongly
encourage the Trump administration to
look at this as an opening and to push
incredibly hard to just get the deal
done now last week a State Department
diplomat met face to face with Iranian
officials and did plead for the release
of all Americans including Princeton
scholars she u Wang and former FBI agent
Robert Levinson now Gail the Trump
administration does not want another
American to suffer the fate of otto
warmbier he was the student who died
shortly after his release from North
Korea
we remember Margaret nobody wants that
thank you very much